Speaker 1: Today, I'm going to talk about
a topic that comes up often in discussions
around systemic change and individual personal
responsibility.
I got an email over the weekend and this is
why I'm even talking about this today.
The email said, Hey David Cuban American Streamer
Destiny, also known to some in our audience
is Steven Kenneth Destiny Bunnell.
The second was recently interviewed and Destiny
said it's not hypocritical to on the one hand
say, hey, we need these systemic changes.
But on the other hand, to encourage people
to take responsibility and give advice that
tells people individually how to best solve
their situation, even if you're not making
the systemic change.
Now, I haven't been able to find the clip.
Doesn't even really matter because this is
a very important topic and I want to talk
about it today because people have said to
me, I get emails, you know, when we do segments
on the finance, channel, channel, or people
call in during live calls with personal finance
questions or whatever the case may be.
People write to me, they'll say, David, how
can you, in good conscience and in good faith,
advise people about how to reduce their own
tax liability, for example, or work to reduce
your own, but to advocate for higher taxes
for some people?
Or another example recently that came up,
I spoke about funding a 529 college savings
account or educational savings account for
my baby daughter.
And people say, How can you participate in
creating a 529 account for your baby daughter
while saying a huge problem is that college
education is too expensive, there are too
many student loans, The stock market is not
accessible to everyone.
Maybe college education should be less important.
I'm going to address those specific questions,
but let's first set this up properly.
Many people on the right.
And even some on the left will argue there's
a hypocrisy to demanding systemic change while
encouraging people to take responsibility
for their own lives and to do what is best
for them in the moment.
Some will say, and they say it to me, If you
believe in the systemic change, then you should
wait for the government to fix the problem
and not bother trying to improve your situation.
Others might argue when you do what is best
for you, it actually will delay the systemic
solution that you might be calling for.
This is a very flawed and sometimes absurd
argument.
First of all, demanding a systemic change
and encouraging individual action are not
mutually exclusive.
In fact, I would argue they go hand in hand.
Imagine, we want to see a more equal society.
We would like to see a government policy to
reduce inequality in society.
Well, we need to demand policies that address
systemic inequality like a living wage and
affordable housing and universal health care.
And we should vote for candidates who will
do those things or who say they will do those
things.
But at the same time, why wouldn't I encourage
people to educate themselves about how things
are today, how things work today to improve
their skills, to advocate for rights in the
marketplace, to take advantage of the tools
that are available to them, which they might
not even know about to improve their lives.
Today, as we work to elect officials who will
make the bigger systemic change.
Secondly, for me, as a progressive, demanding
systemic change is not about giving up personal
responsibility.
It's about acknowledging Here's all the things
I can do.
But there is a superstructure, a systemic
reality that is above and beyond what I can
do.
It doesn't mean I don't do the things I can
It means I understand there's a second layer
to it.
Some on the right like to say, Listen, you
want health care for all so that you, David,
as a self-employed person, don't have to buy
your own health care.
That's what I do right now.
Sure, maybe.
But I'm going to get myself health care because
I need health care.
It's not really about whether I am getting
health care on the marketplace, the healthcare.gov,
while saying everybody should get it.
These are two different things.
We're all products of our environment and
our choices are limited by the opportunities
and obstacles that exist systemically.
But within that, we should still do what we
can do to improve our situation.
And if we want to empower people to succeed,
we should create a society that provides equal
opportunity when it comes to education and
health care and other economic opportunities.
Last thing.
Encouraging individual action also doesn't
mean we ignored the systemic inequality.
I would argue it's the opposite.
When I say to people, Here are the actions
you can take.
I'm empowering them to do that and better
set themselves up to challenge the status
quo and to demand that change.
When we encourage workers to organize and
demand better wages and working conditions,
we're trying to improve their lives, but we're
also trying to make a systemic change that
will benefit more than just them.
Now, let's talk about some of the specifics
as they apply to me or people that sometimes
call in or whatever the case may be.
IP Let's talk about taxes.
I pay every dollar in taxes that I'm legally
required to pay at a systemic level.
I think we need higher top tax rates.
We should look at taxing capital gains as
income.
We should eliminate the carried interest loophole.
We should shift the tax burden away from the
poor.
All of these different things at the individual
level.
Me David Pakman just sending more money to
the IRS and not taking deductions that are
available to me.
That's not policy.
That it's just that's not the way we do it.
My policy opinion is the one I just told you
and I vote for elected officials that would
put that in place for everyone at the individual
level.
I'm not going to pay more tax than I'm legally
required to pay.
I'm not going to send money to the IRS for
no reason.
There is no double standard.
The problem isn't individual taxpayers.
It's the systemic loopholes and tax breaks
that let the wealthy and corporations evade
taxes.
The 529 account for my daughter.
I'll do this one.
If college costs keep going up as they happen
by the time my daughter is 18.
The colleges I went to would cost over $200,000
a year.
That's insane.
Seems can't possibly happen.
I spoke to Adam Schiff about this.
The student loan industrial complex is a mess.
Maybe jobs should not require a college degree,
and that'll put downward pressure on the cost
of college.
Maybe.
Maybe not.
But what do I gain by denying my daughter
a 529 account that I can start funding today?
I will advocate for change and I will also
do what I think gives me the best insurance
policy.
She doesn't go to college or she doesn't need
the money from the 529 because we fix the
cost of college or whatever in 18 years.
I can change the beneficiary or take the money
out and pay the 10% penalty, whatever.
Now to an advice example.
If someone came to me and said, I'm struggling,
I need to make some more money or I want to
make more money, am I going to rant to them
about income inequality, tax loopholes for
the rich and that we should have universal
basic income?
Those are systemic ideas.
I would tell them, Have you looked at a side
business?
Is there a certificate you can get to earn
more money at your current job?
Is your resume updated?
Is there a skill you can monetize?
There is not a hypocrisy or double standard
between advocating for systemic change and
in the meantime advising people to do what
is best for their families.
When people we have a caller who called in
and said, I have a transfer, my partner is
trans or my daughter is trans, I live in a
deep red state.
It's getting really ugly.
They're passing all this legislation systemically.
We should work in every state to protect trans
people.
At the individual level, I said to them, You've
got to decide for yourself.
Do you need to move to a different state if
you're able to in order to do what you think
is best for your family right now?
Sure.
In 20 years we might effectively protect trans
people in whatever state it was they were
calling from.
But in the immediate, if your family's in
danger, I'm going to say, no, you've got to
stay there.
And of course not.
Okay.
Not a double standard.
Let's understand the difference between the
systemic and structural and the individual.